[Música]
boa tarde eu tive que ricos rapaz ali
atrás
ele falou assim mas você tinha o cabelo
vermelho falei mas eu era nova
agora fiquei loura que a mulher não fica
grisalho ficar loura mas era eu mesmo
mas hoje a gente vai falar de outra
coisa que a gente hoje a gente vai falar
é de ansiedade e é óbvio que todo mundo
já ouviu falar muito de ansiedade muito
de medo a gente vai fazer um micro
resumo de algumas palavras chaves para
que a gente possa falar uma mesma
linguagem e que a linguagem é essa a
linguagem do medo ansiedade e stress que
todo mundo fala muito de estresse todo
mundo fala muito de medo
todo mundo fala de ansiedade mas não
diferencia a coisa mais importante que a
gente saiba que a ansiedade medo stress
praticamente são a mesma coisa ea gente
vai fazer essa pequena diferença e tem a
ver com o mecanismo do nosso cérebro que
foi projetado há muito muito tempo atrás
e que já vem de fábrica já vem no nosso
dna para nos proteger para fazer com que
a gente sobreviver se é pra fazer com
que a gente chegasse até aqui certamente
se não houvesse um mecanismo do medo
ansiedade do stress
nós não teríamos sobrevivido para contar
a história da nossa espécie e não
estaríamos aqui com certeza não
estaríamos aqui então estresse o que o
stress
o estresse é o mecanismo são as
alterações bioquímicas que acontecem nos
no no organismo quando eu presenciou
quando vivenciou uma situação de medo ou
ansiedade medo ansiedade são a mesma
coisa são primos irmãos são as duas
faces de uma mesma moeda
a diferença é que o medo eu tenho
exatamente o que me causa essa reação de
fugir o de lutar por exemplo os homens
primitivos tinham medo de animais
maiores e que eles tinham que sair à
caça então isso é medo ansiedade já o
medo subjetivo não é algo que eu digo eu
tenho medo disso é que nem por exemplo
pessoas que dizem que têm medo de barata
eu nunca vi uma manchete de jornal
dizendo mais barata mata mata mulher
paulada depois que ela identifica ela na
pia
nunca não existe isso mas por que isso
ocorre porque esse mecanismo do medo da
ansiedade e do estresse
tatham é bem marcado no nosso cérebro
porque a gente tinha que sobreviver e
sobrevivemos mecanismo absolutamente
perfeito
aí a gente vai perguntar agora bom e
agora quais são os nossos medos quais
são a nossa qual é a nossa ansiedade no
mundo moderno mudou
provavelmente o homem primitivo jamais
imaginou que a gente e até medo de
atentado terrorista dentro de sala de
aula que a gente é ter medo é de
seqüestros que a gente ia ter medo de
auto-estradas que a gente morreria tanto
pilotando ou dirigindo de forma
inadequada carros
é óbvio que a gente vem evoluindo mas o
cérebro da gente ainda mantém esse
circuito de sobrevivência de alerta de
perigo praticamente igual e o que mudou
então por que vocês vão dizer assim o
homem primitivo ele precisava caçar
ele precisava arrumar um lugar para se
abrigar ele precisava é pegar o animal
para pegar sua pele para se vestir
ele precisava de muitas coisas hoje
praticamente nós não temos gasto
energético em sobrevivermos em termos de
comida em termos de abrigo em termos de
alimentação eu nunca vi ninguém no
supermercado é matar uma galinha levar
pra casa para poder preparar ela já está
lá a fatia a dinha né pra que a gente
tem esse conforto e por que então que a
gente vive adoecendo de tanto stress de
tanto transtorno de ansiedade como
pânico como toque né como ansiedade
generalizada o que aconteceu se o nosso
mecanismo de alerta que era tão preciso
preocupar quando éramos homens muito
primitivos lá no
período paleolítico neolítico o que
aconteceu se hoje a gente não tem tantas
ameaças uma coisa aconteceu
o cérebro da gente ganhou um novo
designer totalmente é revolucionário
a gente tinha um cérebro se a gente for
lembrar dos macacos com lobo frontal que
atesta bem estreitinha e hoje a gente
tem um cérebro com uma testa um pouco
mais alongada e o lobo frontal cresceu e
cresceu muito mas ele cresceu pra dentro
eles se curvou e entrou por dentro do
nosso olho e isso é fantástico
o designer que nos projetou é um gênio
porque porque senão nós estaremos na rua
com cabeças de manga o lobo frontal pra
cima e se lobo frontal gente é o logo da
inteligência né
o antes ele era menor a gente vivia
muito mais instintivamente a gente vivia
de dever ou perceber perigos em todo
lugar
a gente vive em função dos nossos
sentidos e dos nossos sentimentos com a
evolução do lobo frontal
nós passamos a viver muito mais do nosso
raciocínio do nossa cognição da nossa
inteligência
mas o que aconteceu o cérebro mudou mas
parece que a gente é que não notou o que
a gente tinha que fazer
qual é o sentido da vida por um homem
primitivo sobreviver
qual é o sentido da vida do homem
moderno
ele tem toda a inteligência a seu favor
o grande problema é que a gente não sabe
qual o sentido da vida nem o propósito
da vida o sentido da vida seja quem for
pra quem for pra qualquer um de nós é
usar nossos talentos nosso dom e fazer
isso para sermos pessoas melhores para
nós e para os outros também que o
propósito é compartilhar isso com o
máximo de pessoas
então o propósito da nossa vida é dar
sentido a ela e nós não temos feito isso
nós estamos vivendo exatamente como
viver nossos ancestrais tendo medo de
tudo querendo
controlar tudo nós ganhamos
inteligências mas queremos controlar o
mundo não vamos controlar o mundo
se a gente não quiser engordar as
estatísticas das pessoas que no futuro
vão adoecer de ansiedade depressão
suicídio e vícios compulsões em geral a
gente vai ter que rever a nossa evolução
e vai ter que entender que a nossa
inteligência tem que ser melhor usada e
usada pra que a gente possa de fato
evoluir
de alguma maneira a gente começou a
entender que é ser feliz ou está feliz
ou o sentido da vida era algo em manada
que foi vendido pra gente né
a gente comer tem muito medo hoje
subjetivo de não ser bem sucedido de não
tirar nota que acham que a gente merece
de não ter condições de comprar as
coisas que não status mas a gente
esqueceu que esse não é o sentido da
vida
até porque a gente qual é o sentido da
vida racionalmente falando a gente mas
'carequinha' ascendente e sem saber nada
aí a gente leva anos aprendendo e
crescendo cabelo trocando os dentinhos e
um belo dia a gente começa a envelhecer
e perder isso tudo inclusive os cabelos
vermelhos né
a gente vai deixando os cabelos brancos
a gente vai perdendo dentro a gente vai
perdendo também a nossa o nosso
conhecimento acumulado
qual o sentido lógico disso nenhum
nenhum sentido
isso significa que de forma totalmente
burra a gente continua acionando os
mecanismos de medo e ansiedade
como éramos quando eram os homens
primitivos
o que nós temos que fazer se a gente não
fizer adoecer de ansiedade
existem outros circuitos muitos outros
circuitos dentro do cérebro e os
circuitos que vão fazer a gente cumprir
o nosso sentido da vida nascente da vida
de ser
melhor pra nós e para os outros
ele começa quando a gente começa a usar
outros circuitos do cérebro que estão
muito pouco utilizados que são os
circuitos da empatia o circuito da
argentina leza e o circuito da compaixão
as pessoas falam muito disso mas não
pratico eu vejo muita gente tem empatia
mas empatia por empatia gente é nada
empatia significa que eu me sensibilizo
com o sofrimento do outro o ok mas o que
eu faço pra mudar o sofrimento do outro
se eu não tiver com o paixão eu não faço
nada
a compaixão é que me faz agir para
diminuir o sofrimento do outro a
gentileza é um circuito que a gente
pratica e que a gente vai abrindo novos
circuitos no cérebro
quem de nós esse programa aqui pra fazer
coisas desse tipo
aí depois falar se eu ando tão
estressado não tem jeito um circuito
antigo como era o circuito do medo
ansiedade
ele só vai ser desativado ou mais ou
menos equilibrado se a gente acionar
outros circuitos e os circuitos que nós
temos que acionar são cisco o circuito
da solidariedade
o circuito da gentileza da generosidade
só assim nós vamos ter menos ansiedade
vamos ter menos medo e vamos viver no
mundo um pouquinho melhor
não é uma utopia o que eu tô falando é
simplesmente um conhecimento em cima
daquilo que o cérebro mostra pra gente
nós ganhamos um cérebro novo mas
utilizamos ele como se ele ainda fosse
velho
a culpa é nossa porque porque a gente
não usa o conhecimento para mudar as
coisas a gente hoje a grande maioria das
pessoas vive em movimento de manada não
precisa muita gente vai ao shopping
se tiver uma loja cheia todo mundo que
entrar na loja cheia ninguém ela vazia
então a gente anda reproduzido
comportamentos e se a gente para pessoa
e fala qual o sentido da sua vida ter
filhos
a família constitui uma família ter um
trabalho não é o sentido da vida é o
meio para se chegar ao sentido da vida
que é o sentido da vida gente é a gente
que faz dar sentido à vida
talvez tenha sido o que um cérebro tão
maravilhoso nos fez ver eu não tem não
tem sentido lógico se não tem eu tenho
que dar sentido a isso e dar sentido a
isso é lembrar que nós estamos aqui não
para sermos satisfeitos o tempo todo
para poder estar alegre o tempo todo
nós estamos aqui pra evoluir ea evolução
passa por sair da zona de conforto e em
direção ao outro
queremos ou não nenhum de nós está
desconectado do outro
se a gente não entender isso não aceitar
que a vida é breve é passageira mas que
nós estamos aqui para evoluir
a gente vai o tempo todo tá em stress
porque a gente quer mudar o que não pode
ser mudado
a gente quer ser eterno mas a gente não
é justamente não podemos ser eternos
porque senão não cumpriríamos nossas
tarefas em outra coisa se a gente não
conseguir entender o sentido da vida e o
propósito da vida que é distribuir isso
abrir essa generosidade através dos
nossos talentos para todos que tiverem
nosso redor e o máximo de pessoas que a
gente tiver nós também não conseguimos
a tal da evolução espiritual o que a
evolução espiritual e não estou falando
absolutamente de religião
eu tô falando de espiritualidade
espiritualidade tem a ver com sermos
melhores entendermos que nós passaremos
mas a humanidade continua ea gente tem
que ter o compromisso de passar o bastão
para as pessoas que viram ciel é me
ponho no mecanismo absolutamente egoísta
né uso todo o meu circuito de
sobrevivência para competir pra querer o
mal do outro
pra não ter a gentileza eu seguro
conhecimento eu estou adoecendo sem
perceber e isso não é o meu só a mim o
meu ponto de vista
as pessoas estão adoecendo exatamente
por isso vamos ter muitos mais quadros
de ansiedade vamos porque as pessoas
ainda não entenderam que estamos de
passagem e evolução espiritual no fundo
seria nossa conexão com tudo que há de
melhor no universo um chamado de deus
outros chamam de alá outros chamam dos
orixás
não tem a menor importância a
importância é que a gente possa se
conectar com essas energias pra que a
gente se reabasteça e possa dividir isso
entre todos nós existir adoecimento sim
é muito menos porque a gente vai
praticar o desapego o desapego de não
sermos eternos de não temos a pretensão
de mudar as pessoas
as pessoas mudam quando elas querem e eu
não conheci nunca algo mais
revolucionário do conhecimento
a gente não deve aceitar aquilo que
dizem pra gente a gente deve estudar pra
que a gente possa de fato dizer eu estou
agindo assim porque isso me faz bem
por exemplo se você praticar uma
gentileza
você vai se sentir bem aí você vai falar
assim não me senti tão bem no início
faça a segunda faça terceira porque o
mecanismo da competitividade do medo ele
estacionado há muito tempo
o mecanismo é da gentileza da empatia da
compaixão ele precisa ser ativado até
porque a gente entende que não dava pra
ser tão empático gentil numa um planeta
que a gente não tinha nada a gente não
tinha como comer a gente não tinha como
se abrigar
a gente não tinha como fazer essas
coisas mas hoje nós temos e o que a
gente está fazendo a gente se comporta
como crianças que querem seus brinquedos
sozinho pra gente enquanto qualquer um
o mundo estiver mal nós também estaremos
é difícil raciocinar assim mas a física
quântica prova que não tamos
desconectado de nada ao ferir uma pessoa
você se refere também ao fazer mal uma
pessoa pode ter certeza que você estará
falando mal pra você também se a gente
não entender que essa base do
adoecimento é tá na nossa mão tá no
nosso conhecimento
a gente vai evoluir para adoecer
eu nunca vi uma pessoa que esteja ciente
do sentido da vida real do propósito da
vida real e que acredite na
transcendência da vida energeticamente
falando que pare para adoecer é difícil
mas o grande dificuldade é que a gente
tenha essa noção
então assim eu peço a vocês que se não
levarem nada daqui hoje que levem tipo
assim que se responda qual o sentido da
minha vida
se você responder só coisas práticas tem
alguma coisa errada
o seu filho e sua família isso tudo é o
meio mas não é o fim
no sentido da vida o sentido da vida é
muito maior e aí se a gente pensar bem é
tem um toque divino na evolução
espiritual
acho que sim eu chamo deus do design do
universo porque eu tenho profunda
admiração principalmente porque ele
criou e fez a coisa mais extraordinária
do mundo que é o nosso cérebro e aí eu
deixo com vocês uma imagem que eu acho
que vale mais do que mil palavras que a
imagem de miguel ângelo do do quadro
lindo que está na capela sistina que a
criação do primeiro homem né
e reparem um detalhe não sei se vocês
estão vendo aí tal estão vendo deus lá
no cantinho separar o que deus está
dentro de um cérebro é um cérebro isso
aí gente de alguma maneira
deus criou fez a sua melhor criação
o cérebro humano e isso tem algum motivo
talvez porque ele através dele se
comunique com a gente mas a gente tem
que abrir os portais desse cérebro de
forma a sermos mais humanos na acepção
mais concreta e transcendente da palavra
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]